why don't we get to meet all of the
Disney Princesses kids in The
Descendants movies some of them actually
appear in the novels the animated TV
shorts and the webseries but why not the
films we're revealing the truth behind
why these Disney kids didn't make the
cut
keep watching to the end to discover
which Disney kid got deleted from the
films even though an actor had been cast
to play the role I see a strong
confident beautiful young lady
princesses with kids in The Descendants
movies first up let's look at the
princesses who do have kids attending
auradon prep in the movies of course
there's Belle and her son Ben Cinderella
also has a son at the school chad
charming Aurora has a daughter Audrey
and Mulan has a daughter
Monni we see Belle in the movies a lot
but did you know the other three
princesses also appear briefly you have
to look very closely during Ben's
coronation in the first film Cinderella
Aurora and Mulan plus their husbands are
all at auradon Cathedral okay so that's
four princesses and their kids but what
about the other ten princesses some of
those princesses actually appear in the
film's themselves
Snow White is shown clearly as the
reporter during Ben's coronation
keep watching to hear our theory about
who her kid could be and jasmine also
features overtly
making a cameo with Aladdin in
descendants 2 we see them having a meal
with mal and then during a news item
stay tuned to learn the truth about
Jasmine's child as for the other
princesses that pop up in the movies you
have to look real close to spot them
they appear in the second movie during
ben's royal cotillion take a look on the
balcony and you can spot ariel and tiana
up there along with their husbands but
what about their kids Disney kids that
appear in The Descendants world but not
the movies some of the princesses
actually do have kids in the descendants
world even though they haven't appeared
in the movies yet they're the characters
were really interested in but why aren't
they featured in the films to discover
which other Disney kids exists in this
world we need to take a look at the
books TV shows and web series that
includes The Descendants novels by
Melissa de la Cruz and the animation
shorts in the TV series called
descendants wicked world plus the
live-action shorts in the TV and web
series called descendants school of
Secrets that series involves a secret
camera in the cafeteria which
iZON Arden prep students but first let's
reveal which princess has two children
in the dissonance world even though only
one of them appear in the film's great
she brings home a sword if you ask me
she should have brought home a man
excuse me this family man lives here
Mulan son lil Shang we get to see
Mulan's daughter Lani in the dissonance
movies but did you know Mulan has
another child in the descendants world
he's called li Shang junior or lil shank
he appears in the novel's by Melissa de
la Cruz so the question is why doesn't
he appear in the movies well it's
probably because he's too old
he's Lonnie's older brother so he's not
in the same school year as the main
characters little shang appears in the
descendants novel titled rise of the
Isle of the Lost we discover he's a
recent graduate of auradon prep and now
he's on a gap year working as an
assistant
rora coach at the school that's the
sport Jay and Lani play in the second
film that's a mix of parkour and fencing
with swords in the book lil Shing helps
Jay learn the moves teaching him how to
wield a saber we learned that after his
gap year lil shang plans to go back home
to the northern wei kingdom to rule
although it would be so awesome to see
him in the movies we could understand
why he doesn't appear the truth is he
probably wouldn't have much to do with
the plot lines or the other characters
Rapunzel's daughters Ruby and antolín
Rapunzel is another princess that has
more than one child in the descendants
world but we don't get to see either of
her daughters in the movies or do we
eagle-eyed fans have spotted a girl with
long blond hair wearing a purple dress
that totally looks like she could be
Rapunzel's daughter she appears briefly
during the be our guest musical number
she's standing on the far left of the
back row there's also some debate about
whether Rapunzel has two daughters or
just one in the Disney Channel animated
short series descendants wicked world
there's a character called Ruby we only
ever see her hair as Audrey says Ruby's
hair leaves ten minutes after she does
it's thought that ruby has an older
sister called Anne Celyn and we
definitely get to see one of Rapunzel's
daughters in the webseries School of
Secrets in these online shorts we see a
girl dressed in purple with short blond
hair she talks about her mom spending
half her
weightiness Hauer so it's pretty
definite she's Rapunzel's daughter she's
dating chad charming and discovers that
he's also dating Ariel's knees as well
as most of the other princesses at the
school wouldn't be amazing if that love
triangle made it into one of the movies
that is something we'd love to see so
the question is why don't we pencils
daughters have major roles in the movies
the truth is they're probably just isn't
enough room for another a K or two after
all the descendants movies are more
focused on the V Ches
perhaps that's why this next a K didn't
make the cut either Ariel's daughter
melody so we know Ariel has a niece that
exists in the descendants world and
Ariel herself shows up in the
descendents movies during bends
cotillion so Ariel is definitely part of
that world but let's not forget that
Ariel also has a daughter who exists in
her own films and that melody in fact
out of all the Disney Princesses with
sequel movies Ariel is the only one who
has a child so why didn't they include
melody in The Descendants movies sure
she's the most obvious choice given that
she's the only one who actually exists
it might be because melanie is not
featured in the original little mermaid
film we meet melody in the second movie
The Little Mermaid to return to the sea
and there's a theory amongst fans that
only the first movie counts for Canon in
The Descendants world there's another
reason why melody might have been left
out she's only 12 years old in her movie
in the AKS that are done proper older
than that Finn's coronation takes place
because he's turning 16 sure melody
could be the same age as them now after
all the events of her film take place in
an unspecified amount of time after the
original but as fans will picture melody
as a 12 year old they might have trouble
adjusting to her as a 16 year old
however we think she could turn up as a
younger student she'd be the perfect BFF
for dizzy
if melody were in the movies it would
also make umas role even more important
after all uma the daughter of Ursula
Ariel's great enemy Snow White
we loved seeing snow white as a reporter
at Ben's coronation in the first movie
who knew that the quiet princess would
turn out to have such a fun career
unlike Rapunzel we don't have any proof
that Snow White has a child in the
dissonance universe but we have a
the area about who it could be they say
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
so it makes total sense the snow-white
child would be a reporter too and we get
to see a character just like that in the
webseries
school of secrets in day 22 the secret
cameras spine on a meeting about the
Arden scroll this is the school student
web site and the editor is a girl that
could totally be Snow White's daughter
she has dark hair just like the princess
wouldn't it be great if they turned this
small part into a major role in the
movies after all they should really have
the a K to match the VK evey is the
daughter of the villain from the snow
white movie so it would be so
interesting to see what her relationship
would be like with the daughter of the
heroine of that movie what would Snow
White's daughter think of evey the
daughter of the villain who tried to get
rid of her mom Malin Audrey's
relationship is fascinating because of
that dynamic
come on descendants give us what we want
nobody's gonna have those a cotillion
Jasmine's son
Aziz here's another interesting Disney
kid that exists in the descendants world
but didn't make the cut for the movies
jasmine and Aladdin son Aziz appears in
the descendents novels in the Isle of
the Lost
novel Audrey tells Ben they're going to
visit Aziz and money and in the return
of the Isle of the Lost novel Aziz seems
to be friends with Jay this is
intriguing given that Jay is the son of
Jafar Aziz's parents enemies but it gets
even more fascinating he said in spans
talk about Aziz as a deleted character
that means he was originally planned to
appear in the movies but was cut out for
unknown reasons word on the street is
that descendants bosses had even cast
Canadian actor Deshawn Loyola to play
the part we see as Dee's in the
descendants yearbook publication - he's
listed in the tourney team and his
jersey number is 11 he's such a shame
that this Disney kid was left out of the
movies in the end wouldn't it have been
enthralling to see how his friendship
with Jay would have played out the novel
has them as friends and the fact that
they're both on the tourney team means
they have spent a lot of time together
we'd love to see all the DK's
interacting with the AKS that their
villain parents were enemies with we
only get to see that dynamic in
relationship to Sleeping Beauty with Mal
and Audrey as the villain and heroines
offspring there's also a fan theory
J is actually jasmine and Aladdin his
son and Jafar stole him from them that's
a whole other story all the other
princesses kids so that leaves us with
the question what about all the other
princesses kids we've looked at eight
princesses so that leaves six let's
start with Tiana we get to see her at
the cotillion
so she exists in that descendants movie
and in that descendants yearbook we just
mentioned there's a player called Tyrone
on the tourney team there's been some
chatter amongst fans that Tyrone is
Tiana's son we loved the idea of her boy
hanging out with Jay on the tour knee
field
whoever Tiana's child is we think he or
she would love cooking too given who
their mom is it would be awesome if
Tiana skit appeared in descendants three
after all Tiana's enemy dr. facile ear
is appearing in the film along with his
daughter Celia his daughter Freddy
appeared in the animated descendants of
wicked world series - as for Pocahontas
we've got a theory about who her kid
could be as the disney princess is based
on an actual person we can look at how
her life really turned out and she did
have a son whom she named thomas however
John Smith wasn't the dad in Disney's
depiction as in Pocahontas is real life
she ended up with a different Englishman
John Rolfe we get to see how she meets
him in her sequel movie called
Pocahontas to journey to a new world
they end up sailing back to Virginia
after falling in love in England in real
life Pocahontas did marry John Rolfe
although it didn't play out quite like
that she passed away when her son was
still very little we'd like to think her
son Thomas would enjoy life at art on
prep we think he'd be best buddies with
Ven as for Moana and Merida were not
convinced they necessarily have kids yet
we are told that our Don was created 20
years before the events of The
Descendants movies if each of the
princesses was the age in their movie
when our don was created then that puts
Merida and rowana at 36 years old now
they were both 16 in their films Moana
wanted to travel Merida didn't want to
settle down and get married
perhaps their boats still enjoying their
adventures before motherhood if in fact
they ever have kids we wonder if that's
also the case for Elsa however we could
totally see Anna having several kids
perhaps she couldn't bear to part with
them and so she homeschooled
instead of sending them to board at our
Adhan prat so there you have it our take
on why these Disney kids aren't in The
Descendants movies which kids would you
like to see turn up in the films let us
know in the comments section below a
nice women is a reckless disregard of
the rules don't you know stop dude
thanks for watching make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one we'll see you next time
[Music]